[موسيقى]
لا اظن ذلك على الاقل في المدى القريب او
المدى المتوسط ربما في المدى البعيد تحدث
تغيرات في طبيعه الذكاء الاصطناعي اقصد
البنيه التحتيه التي اسس عليها لكن حاليا
والله اعلم انا لا اظن ان تمت يعني خطر
على البشريه والسبب في ذلك ان هذه النماذج
هي نماذج لغويه اساسا بمعنى ان يتم تدريب
نماذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي على نصوص كبيره يعني
نصوص هائله وبالتالي
عندها قدره على التنبؤ في ما سياتي بعد
انا لا ارى اي مشكله في ذلك يعني نحن لم
نصل الى المرحله التي يكون فيها الذكاء
الاصطناعي قادرا على التفكير بذاته
والشعور بنفسه
[موسيقى]
الضمانات الموجوده كما قلت يعني مسبقا ان
النماذج الحاليه للذكاء الاصطناعي حقيقه
ليست بالتطور الكبير التي يعني الذي يتيح
لها ان تقوم بمثلا
الحاق الادب الناس او تدمير مثلا بعض
الهيكريات او المنشات الحكوميه مثلا او
المنشات المدنيه هذا الكلام يعني بعيدا
المدى يعني اما كيف يمكن للمطورين اذا ما
يعني تتطورت هذه النماذج اللغويه كيف
يمكننا التحكم فيها يعني ابسط شيء على
الاقل يعني قد تكون هناك كلمات مفتاحيه
كلمه مرور معينه بحيث اذا شذ البرنامج عن
المعايير الموضوع له يمكن استدعائه مره
اخرى او تحييده او ايقافهم
حتى لا يتم يعني تجاوز الامر الى ما يمكن
ان يضر بالبشريه
نعم اظنه كذلك نحن شهدنا
مراحل كثيره من التطور يعني انا شخصيا
ربما لا يفصح عن عمري يعني استخدمت
كمبيوتر صخر وقمت بتسجيل بعض النصوص عليه
باستخدام الكاسيت
[موسيقى]
الى اي مدرسه في الاسره هذه النماذج وهل
سيكون منها ما هو فيه خطر على البشريه ام
لا
[موسيقى]
نعرف كيف سيغير طبيعه الحياه ونحن نعلم ان
التغيير دائما بالخوف يعني الناس حينما
تقول مثلا موظف هناك مثلا برنامج جديد او
هناك مثلا
منصه جديده تسرع العمل اول ما سيتبادئ الى
ذهني هل سافقد وظيفتي هل ستتاثر وظيفتي
الى اخره فبالتالي المخاوف موجوده ثم
مخاوف ايضا من الاستخدام المنصات المنصات
الذكاء الاصطناعي لمثل الاهداف غير شرعيه
مثلا او اهداف ارهابيه او يعني الى اخره